c'est grand retour du Black Friday des
fêtes de Noël bref c'est la fin de
l'année et c'est moment de donner ma
sélection de produits pour cette fin
d'année je vous ai fait plusieurs
catégories il y aura du smartphone il y
aura des mondes colncté des tablettes
bon aussi beaucoup pour la maison du
Smart home il y a un peu de stockage en
gros je vais vous montrer le matos que
j'utilise une partie du matos que
j'utilise des choses que je vais venir
vous recommander que je pense vous ne
connaissez pas on va parler aussi un peu
d'audio rapidement de PC un peu de
caméra si vous voulez un peu de matos
pour venir vous filmer ça c'est plus sur
la fin cette vidéo est chapitrée donc
vous avez toutes les infos vous pouvez
donc aller sur la catégorie qui vous
intéressere point intéresse sont tous
les liens des produits sont des liens
d'affiliation ils sont dans la
description vous pouvez y aller cliquer
dessus comme ça vous découvrirez alors
la première chose on va se parler un peu
de smartphone je vous dis tout de suite
je vous mets le lien aussi dans la
description allez voir regardez cette
vidéo bien évidemment jusqu'au bout
parce qu'il y a plein de jolies
surprises mais je vous fais tous les
mois une vidéo pour savoir quel
smartphone venir acheter la vidéo du
mois de novembre est sortie la vidéo du
mois de décembre sortira bientôt donc je
vous montre rapidement quelques produits
coû cœur que j'aime beaucoup il y en a
plein d'autres donc allez jeter un coup
d'œil à cette vidéo là on va commencer
tout de suite par un produit qui un peu
incontournable qui est vendu un tarif
assez cool c'est le Galaxy A54 5G qui
coûtait normalement un peu moins de 500
balles là il y a 80 € de remise chez
Samsung tout de suite là une fois de
plus les liens sont juste en bas 419 €
très bon smartphone capteur photo qui
est très correct dans le milieu de gamme
ça marche bien je vous le recommande il
y a suffisamment de performance vous
avez un très bel écran de 6,4 pouces
c'est du Super AMOLED 120 Hz donc c'est
fluide pour tout ce qui expérience de
visionnage de jeux de film de séries
c'est très très cool le capteur
principal de 50 mégapixel est maîtrisé
bonne autonomie bonne expérience c'est
avec Samsung derrière bref c'est un
smartphone super intéressant et une fois
de plus à ce tarif là ça vaut le coup
d'aller voir alors autre produit que je
recommande et que j'aime énormément
c'est le pixel 7a chez Google je vous le
monondre parce que je vous le montre sur
le site de Google mais en fait là voyez
une remise à 449 faut pas aller
là-dessus je vous mets notre Clen dans
la description vous allez chez la Fnac
et vous le trouvez à partir de un peu
moins de 400 balles 399 € et le pixel 7a
il est quand même vachement cool alors
là c'est du 128 Go il est super bien
pourquoi parce qu'en fait vous avez
c'est pas la dernière puce c'est pas la
tensor G3 c'est la tensor G j'ai de mais
il est extraordinaire en photo vous avez
deux capteurs grand angle ultra grand
angle ici on vient pas zoomer dans
l'image mais le taf qui va faire en
photo avec la capacité de calcul et
toute l'intelligence artificielle de
Google derrière on fait un excellent
smartphone et un peu moins de 400 balles
c'est totalement imbattable les photos
seront meilleurs que sur le Galaxy A54
que vous allez payer un peu plus cher
c'est pas tout à fait la même expérience
mais pour autant ça reste vraiment un
excellent smartphone autre excellent
smartphone que je vous recommande qui
est très atypique c'est le noing phone 2
qui est proposé un tarif beaucoup plus
intéressant on se parle d'un smartphone
vraiment dans le haut de gamme on a un
superbe écran AMOLED 6,7 c'est très gros
du ltpo avec un tau de rafraîchissement
variable de 1 jusqu'à 120 Hz donc ça ça
joue aussi pour du la fluidité de
l'autonomie c'est très très bon
c'estnapdragon 8 plus Gen 1 qui est
super bien noingos 2.0 la glyf interface
vous savez avec tout ce système lumineux
qui servira aussi bien avec des des
alertes un peu différentes en fonction
de vos appels téléphoniques en fonction
de vos messages si vous avez un minuteur
ça va venir bouger là enfin bref c'est
vraiment vraiment super bien superbe
expérience que je vous recommande
énormément là le tarif est marqué tout
en bas si vous êtes sur le 828 il est un
peu moins de 600 balles franchement
c'est cool 579 et après si on veut
monter un petit peu plus en augmentant
un peu le la rame vous me rajoutez 100
balles de plus 529 mais déjà la version
comme ça en 828 579 c'est vraiment
extrêmement canon autre smartphone que
j'aime beaucoup chez Honor c'est le
Magic 5 Pro qui coûtait 1100 ou 1200
balles je sais plus et là on peut le
toucher un peu moins de 9 100 balles
c'est cher soyons clair mais c'est un
excellent smartphone que ce soit en
terme de photo en terme de vidéo enfin
surtout photo il est extraordinaire
vidéo il est bien mais la photo est
vraiment extraordinaire vous avez un
très très bel écran qui est incurvé des
quatre côtés c'est l'OLED plein de
techno très précises pour lutter contre
le le sentiment donc contre la fatigue
oculaire très lumineux enfin bref voilà
moi j'adore la photo est très bonne
triple capteur de 50 mgapixel Snapdragon
8 gen 2 super smartphone après un autre
qui est vraiment super cool c'est le
Galaxy zflip 5ve avec son plus grand
écran extérieur qui reste quand même un
peu cher soyons clair il coûit 1199 on
trouve à 1099 mais une fois de plus pour
moi c'est un gros coup de cœur donc si
vous voulez vous faire plaisir avec un
smartphone k spit très atypique et très
chouette vous pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés je l'utilisé pendant un bon
moment il est super cool et puis ensuite
autre gros coup de cœur de l'année c'est
le Galaxy S23 ultra qui reste je vous le
dis tout de suite quand même cher il
coûtait 1419 € on le trouve aujourd'hui
à 1199 € c'est quand même mieux mais
c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent
directement sur le site de Samsung et
c'est le Black Friday chez inil profiter
des meilleures réductions de l'année
directement sur leur site avec des
réductions qui vont aller jusqu'à - 55 %
ici il y a pas de code promo vous alleer
directement sur leur site pour profiter
des meilleures réductions chez inochile
vous allez retrouver des coques ultra
résistantes ça va être la solide suite
pour une protection maximale la clear
qui est une coque transparente qui ne
jeit pas mais également la modenx dont
le Verseau est interchangeable à noter
ici que leurs accessoires sont
compatibles avec plus d'une centaine de
smartphones dont bien évidemment les
iPhones notamment les iPhone 15 les
pixel 8 et les Galaxy 6 S23 et plein
d'autres également une fois de plus alle
acheter un cûil directement sur le site
de rindow Shi je vous mets le lien juste
en bas dans la description il y a
également des designs exclusifs la
collection Japon NASA One Piece Naruto
Marvel Dragon Ball NBA j'en passe à des
meilleurs et vous pouvez également venir
customiser vos propres coques moi ici
une coque monsieur Greux mais vous
pouvez également venir protéger vos
écrans avec une toute nouvelle coque
version antilumière bleue sinon vous
avez les classiques la transparente la
MA l'antiespion et même en vert trempé
et vous pouvez également venir mettre
des protections sur vos objectifs photo
mais vous avez également des accessoires
et protections pour votre Apple watch
notamment un bracelet tressé disponible
dans six couleurs qui est à la fois
résistant confortable soup durable qui
se déforme pas et surtout à boitié prix
par rapport au bracelets d'Apple il y a
également la coque crash Garden X pour
venir protéger votre APPLE watch sans
oublier une coque de protection pour
votre étu de airpods voici quelques
exemples de promotion pendant le Black
Friday jusqu'à - 55 % sur les coqus
jusqu'à - 35 % sur les protections
d'écran jusqu'à - 25 % sur les
accessoires et jusqu'à 20 % sur les
design issus de licences prestigieus
c'est donc tout de suite le meilleur
moment pour venir vous équiper en
accessoir et pour venir protéger votre
smartphone et tous vos accessoires
directement chez Rino shield c'est le
Black Friday une fois de plus je vous
mets le lien juste en bas dans la
description et merci à Rino shield
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo on va
ensuite faire un tour du côté des mondes
connectés ça c'est aussi un truc
vraiment cool je l'ai eu au poignier
pendant un bon moment c'est LA Galaxy
watch 6 classique 449 € c'est un beau
budget mais pour une belle expérience
sur Android vous avez un smartphone de
Samsung c'est gen optimal mais si vous
avez un autre smartphone Android il y a
aucun problème soit version 43 mm un peu
plus petit soit 47 mm un peu plus grand
on s'en doutera version Bluetooth suffit
largement puisque vous avez vot
smartphone à côté Bluetooth + 4G bon
version Bluetooth suffit largement
puisque vous avez votre smartphone à
côté Bluetooth plus 4G bon pas
nécessairement sûr que pour tout le
monde ce soit intéressant c'est une
super jolie monte très efficace qui
marche bien le tarif est un peu élevé
mais elle est supra cool une autre monte
qui est géniale uniquement pour les
iphonees ici c'est l'Apple watch se qui
est un peu moins cher qu'une Apple watch
Series 9 par exemple enfin deux fois
moins cher quasiment presque mais qui
reste excellent vous avez tous les
capteurs principaux bien évidemment avec
ça il vous faut un iPhone si un iPhone
est recommandé tout de suite c'est pas
forcément l'iPhone 15 que je vous
recommande c'est l'iPhone 14 pro ou pro
Max qui reste quand même relativement
cher bien qu' a des tarifs intéressants
notamment voyez là sur le site de la
Fnac si vous voulez un iPhone 15 mieux
vaut acheter un 14 pro et si vous voulez
aller un peu plus loin le 15 pro fera
l'affaire mais déjà là le 14 pro il est
magnifique on va faire un tour de côté
des tablettes il y a une offre sur le
Black Friday qui est pas mal chez
Samsung il vous offre deux fois plus de
stockage pour le même prix c'est quand
même pas mal si vous achetez une Galaxy
Tab S9 ultra il vous offre offre une
book cover keyboard slim pour l'utiliser
comme un petit ordinateur et si vous
prenez une S9 S9 plus il vous offre le
book cover déjà très honnêtement de vous
à moi la S9 elle est très cool elle est
chère quasiment 900 balles une table S9
ultra à quasiment 1400 balles c'est
quand même un gros gros budget mais une
très belle tablette dans les haut de
gamme vous pouvez aller sur une table S9
qui est quand même cool avec le stockage
doublé ça vaut le coup maintenant il y
en a une autre que j'utilise beaucoup
alors les iPads je voulais pas qu'il y a
toujours des offres des promos c'est
plutôt bien si vous êtes dans
l'écosystème Apple l'iPad ça reste
l'incontournable il y en a une autre que
moi j'utilise à la maison et que je sais
qu' quand même un peu décrié c'est la
pixel tablette de Google que je trouve
une fois de plus super cool parce que
polyvalent dans l'idée de la maison
connectée moi j'ai utilisé pendant très
longtemps un Google nest hub Max qui me
servait un peu d'interface piloter à la
voix prendre des infos mais avec la
pixel tablette je vais plus loin je peux
la prendre je peux la détacher de son
socle et la prendre la poser devant moi
typiquement lorsque je préparais une
recette je la prends tac tac ma recette
dessus elle est dans la cuisine à côté
de ma plaque de cuisson soyons clair
c'est cool ensuite lorsque je si je suis
tout seul à manger je la prends je
l'enlève je la pose sur un trépied je me
regarde des vidéos sur YouTube le midi
je fais quasiment tout le temps ça quand
je suis chez moi puis après il y a plein
d'infos bah tout ce qu'on peut retrouver
dans l'écosystème Google et si à côté de
ça vous prenez une sonnette connectée
Google nest dorbell en en parle dans
quelques instants et bien vous pouvez en
plus l'utiliser avec donc ça c'est quand
même supra supra cool c'est un très joli
produit qu'on trouve un peu moins cher à
579,99 € si on vient l'apprendre c'est
qu' pense écosystème Google et qu'on
veut une maison connectée à venir
piloter ici on peut le faire avec avec
une autre tablette mais j'aime beaucoup
l'idée que lorsqu'elle est sur sa base
on a un meilleur son enfin j'aime
beaucoup voilà après je veux qu'on parte
maintenant dans la maison connectée et
il y a un produit qui est un des plus
important des premiers produits à avir
dans sa maison connectée pour se
faciliter la vie au quotidien c'est un
aspirateur connecté alors je vous montre
souvent des produit assez cher il y en a
plein d'autres mais là je vais vous
montrer des gros coups de cœur que j'ai
adoré j'ai testé il y a pas longtemps
c'est le dreamme c'est le L20 ultra là
il y a une offre à un peu plus de 1000
balles il coûtait 1299 ils ont enlevé
200 balles il y a 15 % de remise il est
génial pour plusieurs raisons déjà
regardez il y a ce petit patin qui vient
se décaler sur le côté donc pour les
recoins c'est quand même vachement bien
pour tout très très bien nettoyer sur
les côtés il est très précis scanne bien
on va jusqu'à 7000 Pascal VI se remplir
en eau propre il vide son eau sale il
nettoie il sèche la serpillère quand il
est sur les tapis il la lave bref je
vous mets les liens pour mes vidéos sur
YouTube sur les produits dont je vous
parle parce qu'il est vraiment vraiment
cool et que je l'adore à la maison autre
aspirateur robot il y en a pas dans la
gamme vous pouvez aller acheter un coup
d'œil une fois de plus les liens sont
juste en bas autre aspirateur robot que
j'aime beaucoup c'est le robooc c'est le
S8 pro ultra on est quasiment 1100 €
1111 € il y a in 26 % pendant le Black
Friday c'est aussi un produit qui est
très très bien chez robrooc ça marche
super bien la cartographie est top il
est puissant il aspire bien il nettoie
bien voilà c'est un produit qui est
extrêmement précis et que j'adore
beaucoup et puis un petit troisième pour
vous laisser du choix j'ai testé il y a
pas longtemps non plus c'est l'covax
c'est le dbot T20 omni lui il a une
autre particularité qui est aussi quand
même intéressante c'est que il vient
nettoyer votre sol avec de l'au ch à 55°
donc pour venir enlever les graisses
c'est quand même pas mal il y a le t20e
omni qui lui lave à l'eau froide le T20
omni lui c'est de l'eau chaude et c'est
un produit qui est vraiment aussi supra
supra cool il a un autre sujet qui est
super important c'est le fait de venir
faire des économies d'énergie tout en
optimisant son chauffage à la maison et
bien moi j'utilise un produit que
j'adore c'est le thermostat connecté
intelligent de net atmo celui-là alors
218 balles vraiment je le recommande
vous venez le brancher très très
facilement à votre chaudière là vous
avez un récepteur qui enverra le Swiss
pour venir lancer le chauffage sur votre
chaudière au gaz uniquement et vous avez
ensuite le thermostat qui est qui est
émetteur et qui va envoyer l'information
au récepteur pour envoyer à la chaudière
tu chauffes oui ou non c'est génial
c'est que vous avez une application dans
laquelle vous allez pouvoir créer
différents scénarios en plus de ça si on
souhaite on peut venir coupl des têtes
thermostatique intelligente pour y
réguler en fonction d'une pièce à
l'autre si on a besoin mais déjà la base
de la base de la base c'est d'avoir le
thermostat connecté intelligent en état
de mous je le recommande plus plus plus
pour venir optimiser votre chauffage à
la maison c'est vraiment vraiment supra
cool autre produit pour la mais qui est
extrêmement important et on en parle
très bientôt je vous ferai une grosse
vidéo sur les objets connectés
intelligents à la maison et bien c'est
un système d'alarme aujourd'hui j'ai
testé plusieurs systèmes d'alarme que
j'aime bien harlo ça marche bien netatmt
des trucs aussi qui sont très très bien
et qui vont bien mais il y en a un que
j'adore et que je trouve qu' a vraiment
différent et auudessus c'est Ajax
systemme Ajax c'est une boîte
ukrainienne qui pour l'instant est en
Pologne on comprendra largement pourquoi
et qui a un système qui est super
efficace super précis que vraiment je
vais recommander énormément il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de produits il y a une
grosse profondeur de G mais je vous en
parle une prochaine fois ça c'est votre
hub de base que vous allez brancher sur
votre Box vous allez avoir une sirène
intérieure sirène extérieure c'est des
détecteurs de mouvement avec caméas qui
vont faire trois photos des petites
télécommandes ça c'est pour mettre sur
les fenêtres vous avez aussi des
capteurs qui existent pour la porte il
vraiment une très très grosse profondeur
de gamme il y a énormément d'accessoires
ça c'est vraiment un truc que je
recommande parce que c'est très précis
j'ai pas de faux positif ça marche super
bien ça reste un peu cher mais
croyez-moi c'est génial je vous en
reparle une prochaine fois mais si vous
voulez venir sécuriser votre maison avec
un système extrêmement précis très juste
et beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
produits Ajax système très clairement et
j'adore vraiment vraiment vraiment autre
produit pour la maison qui assez cool
c'est l'idé d'avoir une sonnette
connectée si vous aimez les produits
Google et que vous avez comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure une pixel tablette
benah moi j'ai eu pendant longtemps une
naz d'or belle qui est très cool je vais
changer parce que je suis en train de
regarder pour autre chose je vous
montrerai une prochaine fois j'ai une
autre configuration mais ça c'est quand
même super bien vous l'avez comme ça et
elle existe également en filire à vous
de voir ce que vous voulez mais ça c'est
quand même super bien et puis alors il y
a un autre sujet qui est intéressant si
vous avez pas une télé connectée vous
avez pas les moyens de changer votre
télé pour une télé connectée mais que
vous avez une télé qui fait encore
l'affaire mais vous donnez un petit vent
de fraîcheur comme si vous la connectiez
bien vous pouvez prendre des produits
d'Amazon qui sont très cool entre autres
fir stick TV qui est quand même super
bien puis vous avez le fireecube moi
j'ai un fireecube que j'utilise sur une
télé dont je suis pas très fan de de
l'expérience logicielle donc je le
recommande plus plus plus plus plus on
va parler d'un autre sujet qui est super
important moi en tant créateur de
contenu j'ai besoin de faire beaucoup de
sauvegardes mais peut-être que vous
voulez sauvegarder des choses aussi
par exemple vous avez des photos que
vous voulez sauvegarder des souvenirs
des documents importants et que vous
avez pas envie de confier vos documents
que ce soit Amazon que ce soit à Google
que ce soit à Apple et bien vous pouvez
venir acheter un As pour venir soocker
en toute sécurité vos données à la
maison moi j'utilise un as de sinologie
alors j'utilise un très gros NAS avec 10
disqu vous envez peut-être pas besoin
moi je stock de la vidéo vous avez peêre
pas forcément besoin de ça mais chez
sinologie il y a plein de choses super
intéressantes pour venir faire du
stockage et si vous êtes créateur de
contenu vous avez besoin de stocker des
rush comme moi franchement vous pouvez y
aller c'est supra supra cool super
important et vous mettez en derrière des
disques vous pouvez prendre les Sea gate
Aron Wolf là en en 8 t moi c'est ce que
j'ai c'est quand même super bien et vous
me prenez ça surtout bien en HDD et en
7200 tour minutes vous voyez parlons
maintenant un petit peu d'audio parce
que le Black Friday c'est aussi
l'occasion de venir s'équiper en audio
j'ai un produit que j'aime beaucoup que
j'ai testé qui est pas de cette année
mais qui est super bien ce sont les boss
les QC earbuds 2 qu'on arrive à trouver
un peu moins de 200 balles il coûtit un
peu moins de 300 balles moins 34 % tout
de suite directement sur le site de la
Fnac c'est oufissime alors c'est Black
Friday mais j'imagine qu'il y aura aussi
peut-être des offres pour Noël en
fonction du moment où vous allez venir
regarder cette vidéo une fois de plus
tous les liens sont dans la description
réduction de bruit incroyable qualité
audio qui est vraiment au top super
confort personnellement je les adore
boss fait un énorme travail là-dessus et
je vous les recommande plus plus plus
parenthèse si vous êtes chez Apple il
faut venir regarder les airpods pro 2
2uxe génération avec le boîtier de
charge maxsfe en usbc il y a pas de
promo particulière là-dessus 279 € c'est
un produit qui marche bien autre produit
qui est très cool si vous aimez chez
Sony et bien ce sont les Sony WF 1xm 5
qui sont aussi vraiment bien je dirais
que la différence c'est que boss vous
êtes sur un côté des fois un peu plus
grand public on peut moins venir
gratouiller les les paramètres dans
l'application si vous adorez venir
gratouiller si vous êtes un vrai
technophile et bien vous avez plein
d'options super cool directement dans
l'application de Sony que j'adore pour C
WF 1000xm5 je vous en ai fait une vidéo
jeter un coup d'œil lien dans la
description au lieu de quasiment 300
balles vouleit toucher à 249,99 € - 17 %
c'est toujours moins que ce que propose
BZ ici à 19 donc bon le prix on va chez
Bose mais si vous aimez le côté un peu
tequis et que vous voulez aller sur des
produits de Sony vous pouvez y aller
aussi son très très très cool et alors
il y en a un autre que j'ai beaucoup
aimé aussi la promo est moins fulgurante
c'est du côté de chez Technic et c'est
une très très belle découverte cette
année ce sont les EAH
az80 superbes écouteurs équivalent pour
moi ici de ce qu'on trouve chez BZ ou
chez ou chez Sony l'AP est bien aussi
j'en ai fait une vidéo le lien est juste
en bas la qualité audio est incroyable
la réduction de bruit est incroyable je
dirais qu'aujourd'hui B tous quand même
super bien dans les haut de gamme et ça
fait vraiment des très très très jolis
produits et puis une petite enceinte
pour venir se balader que j'aime bien
aussi c'est Marshall Middleton j'aime
beaucoup Marshall j'aime la gueule qu'on
s produit parce que ce sont aussi des
objets de décoration on est un peu moins
de 300 balles la version crème je suis
un peu moins fan j'aime beaucoup la
version noire qui pour moi est plus le
côté original de Marshall et que j'aime
énormément et puis en audio je v
vraiment vous parler d'une marque super
intéressante à venir voir c'est une
marque française c'est quelqu'un à côté
de chez moi à côté de Clermond auverne
qui fait de la Haute Fidélité avec un
produit qui est très à part très
atypique c'est absolument absolument
c'est la marque et elle a ce ce produit
qui s'appelle le prodige je vous le
recommande beaucoup alors vraiment c'est
de la haute fidélité c'est pas forcément
fait pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde qui veulent avoir une enceinte
chez eux mais si vous voulez une
excellente enceinte haute fidélité un
peu moins de 700 balles 690 € mais c'est
vraiment un produit qui est vraiment
magnifique vous avez les deux côtés en
bois c'est un objet de décoration
également le le son est là je vous
invite vraiment à venir la découvrir
puis en plus eux ils ont vraiment une
histoire çaà dire que à la base il donn
une nouvelle vie a des vieilles radios
et puis il sont dit tiens si on venait
créer nous-même notre notre notre propre
enceinte connecté sur la Haute Fidélité
c'est bien réussi c'est très joli je
vous mets un lien aussi en bas dans dans
la description maintenant je vis qu'on
se parle un petit peu ordinateur je vais
pas vous faire une grosse liste très
exhaustive d'ordinateur il y en a un que
j'aime bien qui est de l'année dernière
mais qui est aussi super cool et qui a
un tarif vraiment intéressant si vous
aimez des ordinateurs aussi un peu tras
écos avec double écran je vous emmène
chez Asus ils ont super bécan chez Asus
c'est le Zenbook pro 14 duo OL LED
magnifique coûtait un peu moins de 2500
balles là il est un peu moins de 2000
balles il y a quand même 500 €
d'économie vous avez un grand écran haut
qui est très très cool vous avez un
deuxième écran en bas qui vous servira
soit pour venir avoir de l'info pour
travailler dessus soit en outil si vous
travaillez sur photoshop par exemple
avoir quelques petits raccourcis qui est
vraiment vraiment bien c'est un peu
compacté au niveau de du clavier ensuite
et du petit trackpad sur le côté mais
une fois que vous avez pris l'habitude
il y a aucun problème et c'est une
machine qui est magnifique et que
j'adore énormément je vous invite à
venir découvrir une fois de plus le lien
est en bas dans la description et puis
mes vidéos bien évidemment sur Youtube
si par contre vous avez déjà un ordi et
que vous voulez plus dans l'idée du
gaming mais pas que d'ailleurs avoir un
clavier absolument incroyable j'en a un
que j'ai vu cette année qui est
oufissime chez Razer c'est le Black
Widow V4 pro oufissime al existe une
version non pro mais la version Pro elle
est folle après on a 269,99 € gros
budget mais ils sont magnifiques hein
clavier mécanique ose poigner en s000
cuir puis une fois de plus toute
l'expérience RGB chroma qu'on trouve
chez Razer personnalisable en fait il
est ouf il est vraiment vraiment génial
et je vous le recommande absolument ici
si maintenant vous êtes comme moi un
créateur de contenu et que vous voulez
une bonne caméra pour venir filmer chez
vous et bien moi j'en ai une que je je
recommande elle est là elle est en top
shot là tout de suite là vous la voyez
pas elle est juste posée là et bien
c'est le Sony Alpha zve1 c'est pas le
zve10 c'est pas le zv1 c'est le
zve1 c'est celui-là alors on est dans le
haut du panier soyons clair on a un
capteur ici de à 7 S3 c'est du plein
format c'est un peu comme mon FX3 que
j'ai ici mais c'est quand même un peu
plus compact et on peut le trouver avec
un un pack avec un objectif de la gamme
fe c'est le 2860 qui est quand même
vachement bien donc pour aller vloguer
en l' extérieur c'est super cool et une
fois de plus la qualité elle est
incroyable il y a plein de super options
à l'intérieur je le recommande
énormément moi je l'ai acheté j'utilis à
la maison je peux dire quasiment tous
les jours mais je le mets en top shot et
des fois quand j'ai besoin de faire des
plans avec deux caméra je le mets enfin
bref le capteur est fou et ça marche
super bien autre produit si vous êtes
créateur de contenu que ce soit sur
smartphone ou sur un boîtier comme moi
tout de suite c'est ce que j'utilise
tout de suite c'est le dji Mike qui est
fou furieux vous allez l'avoir dans un
espèce d'étui qui en fait c'est une
power Bank vous ouvrez vous avez vos
deux émetteurs vous avez votre récepteur
et vous avez en plus des accessoires en
usbc et en Lightning ce qui fait que
vous allez pouvoir venir le mettre sur
un boîtier directement pourfire de la
musique je suis pas convaincu mais vous
allez pouvoir ensuite le brancher
directement sur un smartphone par
exemple moi directement ici sur mon
iPhone comme ça je peux venir
enregistrer je peux enregistrer deux
personnes faire des vidéos directement
avec en posant dans l'iPhone et en
conversant avec quelqu'un moi par
exemple en modinview je suis l'envo et
la personne qui me répond en face et je
tiens l'iPhone enfinf il y a vachement
de choses à faire c'est vraiment quelque
chose que je recommande énormément là on
a un tarif qui est super cool au lieu de
329 on a 249 €. je le recommande
vraiment parce qu'en plus vous P venir
enregistrer directement ici un petit
backup à moin 6 dcibel enfin il y a
plein plein d'options il est très
polyvalent il est génial et le fait
d'avoir une espèce de petite power Bank
là comme ça vous vous êtes jamais prix
de cours vous avez toujours de de de la
batterie autre produit si on veut venir
pousser le côté un peu plus loin quand
quand on vient filmer avec son
smartphone et bien c'est le l'insta 360
flow que je vous ai déjà présenté qui
est un excellent produit 149,90 € au
lieu de 169,90 € très très très cool il
y a différents tarifs une fois de plus
les liens sont en bas dans la
description et puis si vous voulez avoir
un super stabilisateur aussi mais cette
fois-ci pour boîtier et bien vous avez
le dji dji RS3 mini 389 € qui est
également un très joli produit donc
voilà pour cette sélection on se refera
bientôt une autre vidéo pour venir
parler objets connectés à la maison en
attendant si vous voulez venir choisir
votre smartphone et bien vous avez cette
vidéo qui est juste là la vidéo du mois
allez la voir et vous m'en direz des
nouvelles